coming up later in today's presentation
i'm wondering at what point
we're just developing complex math
models to explain
complex math models and we really
haven't you know made much progress
along the interpretability axis so you
have something you don't understand and
you explain it with something you don't
understand
if i have if i have some general formula
just some very general formula
and then i go in there and i go you know
what this formula has
five parameters and if i make this one
.75
and that one one third and this one two
and that one's zero
and i call this the megatron
activation potential and i go and write
a paper about it
that's really just an arbitrary
selection of a bunch of numbers and then
you gave it a fancy
mathematical passport and you got it
published in some journal
and now everybody has to memorize that
as you know the
megatron potential and kind of learn
about it and that's a lot of what's
going on right now is that it's really
just a bunch of hacking
welcome back to street talk today we're
going to be talking about interpretable
machine learning enjoy interpretability
has become one of the most important
topics
in machine learning and it's something
that every data scientist needs to be
familiar with
for hundreds of years we've had simple
interpretable models like
linear regression and rules-based
systems
but in recent years there's obviously
been a huge rise
in more complex bigger non-linear models
and of course predictions from these
models are not
always so easy to explain so as we start
to use these
more powerful non-linear models to
actually make decisions
on real world matters then it's
inevitable that our attention must now
turn
to interpretability and explainability
when i first started learning about
machine learning algorithms
i was told they could be dangerous they
were
hard to understand they were black boxes
but as kristoff lays out it turns out
there is a whole plethora of techniques
out there to explain
why a model made a certain prediction
some models like
low dimensional linear regression are
intrinsically interpretable
you can just look at the model
coefficients and that tells you
exactly how the model is working under
the hood
then there is a whole suite of methods
that will actually work with
any ml model like training a local
surrogate or a global surrogate
there's also shapley values which is a
really cool technique that
allows you to distribute blame for the
prediction
amongst the input features in a really
theoretically sound really principled
way
and then there are domain specific
methods for example
to explain image models you can try to
highlight the most relevant parts of an
input image
by making saliency maps and there's more
you can look at things like example
based explanations
where you try to find the smallest
change in the input data that would
cause the
output prediction to change so maybe
with this
awesome new interpretability toolkit we
can start to dispel that myth
that machine learning models are all
just black boxes that
can't be understood and can't be trusted
christoph molnar is one of the most
important people
in the interpretable machine learning
space in 2018
he released his magnum opus
interpretable machine learning
a guide for making black box models
explainable
interpretability is often a deciding
factor when a machine learning model is
used in a product
a decision process or research
interpretability methods can be used to
discover knowledge
to debug or justify a model
and its predictions to control and
improve the model
to reason about potential biases in the
model as well as increase the societal
acceptance of models but
interpretability methods can be quite
esoteric
they add an additional layer of
complexity and the potential
pitfalls require expert understanding
machine learning models are inherently
less interpretable
than classical statistical models but
typically they have a better predictive
performance
and that's because of their ability to
handle non-linear relationships
and also higher order feature
interactions
automatically but do we have to suffer
this implicit trade-off
between the complexity of a model and
the lack of our ability
to understand it simplistic model
approximations can often mask
important information and be misleading
as a result
in classical statistics there's an
entire field called model diagnostics
to do exactly this to check that
assumptions and simplifications
have not been violated this is something
that does not yet exist in interpretable
machine learning
interpretability has exploded and
matured in the last few years
in particular since the deep learning
revolution
we now have a better understanding of
the weaknesses
and strengths of interpretability
methods
a growing number of techniques are
available at our fingertips
but can lead to the wrong conclusions if
applied
incorrectly is it even possible to
understand
complex models or even humans for that
matter
in any meaningful way that is one of the
questions that we're going to be
discussing this evening
monar also recently released a couple of
papers where he discusses some of the
important pitfalls
of interpretable machine learning
methods so some of the things that
christoph molnar is really concerned
about is the
lack of statistical rigour in iml
methods monar used to be a statistician
also he is exasperated with some of the
misguided causal interpretations from
some of these iml methods
he also points out feature dependence or
situations where you have shared
information between features
it completely breaks many of the iml
methods and and this is something that
he focuses on a lot
he also focuses kind of philosophically
on the broader impact of
interpretability and
what it what interpretability even means
frankly it's it's a very
nebulous term so let's have a quick
flick through this paper interpretable
machine learning
a brief history state of the art and
challenges and as well as pointing out
some of the history of iml methods you
know we'll jump straight into one of the
challenges which is feature dependence
monar points out that feature dependence
makes attribution and extrapolation
problematic this is exactly what happens
in
partial dependency plots for example we
are basically extrapolating and we are
creating fictitious data points that
didn't really exist
and these fictitious data points
probably exist outside of the data
distribution
so monar thinks that the models that we
build
should reflect the causal structure
in the world but of course that is not
really the case most of the time
and he points out that statistical
learning is just reflecting
surface feature correlations not the
true causal structure beneath
these scenes causal structures would be
more robust if we could actually capture
them
and the predicted performance and
learning causal factors
is a conflicting goal which i think not
many people have thought about
so we need to think about when we can
make causal interpretations and a lot of
work is is underway in this field but
being completely frank
this is very nascent there's not really
much out there at the moment
mona also points out this lack of
statistical rigor
having been a statistician himself he
was exasperated when he came into the
iml field just to
see that most iml methods do not even
give you confidence estimates
something which is completely standard
in the statistical world
models and explanations are computed
from data which means
they are subject to uncertainty but this
is something which is just not captured
using current methods he says that we
need to be making distributional and
structural assumptions
he points out this risk of p hacking
something which is prevalent
in the natural sciences this is
something that could be coming to the
world of iml very soon
if we don't start thinking about this
more carefully molnar also points out
that there is no accepted definition
of interpretable machine learning
methods so
it's not entirely clear how we can
compare iml methods to machine learning
models
it's really easy to assess machine
learning models because we have
benchmarks and we have ground truth
labels
right i mean those benchmarks are
fraught with problems as well but
we can't really quantify how correct
an explanation is and it doesn't really
help that there's a taxonomy of
interpretability methods right there are
objective methods like sparsity and
interaction
strength and there are human centered
evaluations from domain experts or from
lay people
and quite often you need to have quite a
lot of technical knowledge to even
understand
these assessments he says that the
setting of machine learning
is too static doesn't reflect how these
models are actually used in practice
and i really love this idea of thinking
about a process rather than thinking
about just the model
so he says we need to have a holistic
view of the entire process
he thinks that we need to think about
how we explain predictions to folks from
diverse backgrounds
how we have interpretability at the
societal level or at the institutional
level
thinking much more broadly than we are
at the moment he also thinks that we
need to reach out to other disciplines
for example psychologists
and social scientists and he thinks that
there's lots of rich knowledge in
computer science and statistics that
we're just not using yet
so in july of last year he also released
this paper
pitfalls to avoid when interpreting
machine learning models
in this paper he points out that there's
a growing number of techniques providing
model interpretations but many
will lead to the wrong conclusions if
used incorrectly and he goes on to point
out many of those pitfalls
for example the first one is assuming
that the model generalizes well so
assuming that the model has been fit
correctly
if the model is under fit or overfit
then the interpretation method
will perform badly as well an
interpretation can only be as good
as the model underlying it so the next
pitfall he points out is the unnecessary
use of complex models
which is to say the use of opaque or
complex machine learning models
when an interpretable model would have
sufficed
which is to say when the performance of
an interpretable model is only
negligibly worse than one of these black
box
models and to be honest this is
something i see all the time i think the
gratuitous use of complex machine
learning models is
something which is really serious one of
the things i don't like about machine
learning is the laziness
i think we should always seek to
understand and simplify problems
wherever we can it's the same thing in
software engineering
we should always be trying to create the
most elegant and
simple and maintainable solution we
shouldn't be trying to over complicate
things and i think that's a very
you know the kiss principle is very
generalizable here
so he recommends to start with simple
interpretable models like
generalized linear models or lasso
models or additive models decision trees
or decision rules
and gradually ratcheting up the
complexity as required
so he also points out that ignoring
feature dependence is super
important right and this is a problem
that many of the iml methods have so he
gives an example of
partial dependency plots where they
extrapolate in areas where the model has
little
uh training data and it can cause
misleading interpretations
so these perturbations produce
artificial data points that are used for
model predictions
which in turn are aggregated to produce
global
interpretation so that's a big problem
another thing he points out is
confusing correlation with dependence so
he gives an example here features with a
pearson correlation coefficient close to
zero can still be dependent and cause
misleading model interpretations
while independence between two features
implies that the pearson correlation
coefficient is zero
the converse is generally false so it's
a pretty cool example here this is
a couple of features that absolutely
have a dependence on each other you can
see it visualized here
but you wouldn't know that if you looked
at the piercing correlation it would
have said that it wasn't significant
another one a misleading effect due to
interactions
so there's a couple of things here
there's the partial dependency plot
on a couple of dependent features and
then he's used a simulation
to kind of trace all of these different
features to see what the predicted label
was
and according to these iml methods there
is actually no
clear dependency between these features
and the predicted outcome
whereas you can see that that's just
blatantly false so something i've been
meaning to do for more than a year now
is to go through
molnar's interpretability book and to
make some bite-sized videos on every
single approach
well connor and i are actually going to
do that over on machine learning dojo
with the first one next week on shapley
values so
make sure you subscribe to dojo and
check that out remember to like
comment and subscribe we love reading
your comments
and we'll see you back next week
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel and podcast
with my two compadres conor tan who runs
the thomas bay's appreciation society
and mit phd dr keith
duggar now um they say that germans are
known for beer
sausages precision and these days
interpretable machine learning
we have an exemplar german on the show
christophe mona
now christoph made waves in the
community
when he released his magnum opus
interpretable machine learning a guide
for
making black box models explainable if a
machine learning model performs well
why don't we just trust the model and
ignore why it made a certain decision
well the problem is that a single metric
such as classification accuracy
is an incomplete description of most
real world
tasks now is according to doshi velez
and kim in 2017
in christoph's book he introduces the
importance of interpretability and
reports an incredibly detailed taxonomy
of interpretability methods and his
style of writing is at times
entertaining
and entirely absent of hype and nonsense
he runs the gamut
of interpretability models so for
example model agnostic methods like lime
and shapley values example-based methods
such as counter-factual examples and
adversarial examples
he motivates the importance of
interpretability methods
but he's also extremely transparent
about its current weaknesses
and pitfalls he's currently finishing
his phd in interpretable machine
learning at the ludwig
maximilian's university in munich after
getting a stats masters from the same
institution
he's recently written several very
interesting papers on interpretable
machine learning
for example pitfalls to avoid when
interpreting machine learning models in
july of 2020
where christoph detailed several
problematic model interpretations
for example ignoring estimation
uncertainty feature interactions or
confusing correlations
with dependents more recently he
published a paper called interpretable
machine learning a brief history
state of the art and challenges while he
acknowledged that the field is maturing
nicely
he also spoke about some of the serious
challenges in iml methods such as the
lack of statistical uncertainty
shared information between features lack
of a clear definition of
interpretability
and the need for a more holistic view
christophe monar it's an absolute
pleasure and welcome to the show
thank you very much for the invitation
glad to be here
you know kristoff i have to say i really
enjoyed your book
i read this actually some months back in
preparation for a completely different
show
i loved how scientific it was you know
it was it was very much
laying out essentially a survey of the
facts a lay of the land
very objective evaluation i had both the
pros and cons you know different
approaches
examples to make them you know more
understandable so kudos to you i thought
it was a great book
very enjoyable very informative i also
loved how it lays out at the beginning
you know what the
what the goals that we're trying to
achieve with with interpretability are
especially kind of
the human goals right like what does it
mean for
an explanation to be good for people
what kind of explanations do people like
and sometimes there can be conflicting
conflicting goals there and i think um
one thing that that i realized from
reading your book
is that that actually explanations can
be
deceptively good yeah like i think i
think the
the the sort of cognitive bias maybe
that we have to look for
contrastive explanations or
counterfactual
explanations like in principle it seems
good it's kind of like
you know i'm sorry uh uh we can't give
you this loan
you know well why not like why why can't
you get this alone well
what we've detected really that you're
uh that you're a deadbeat what do you
mean i'm a deadbeat yeah you know you
never pay your bills
well let's see why okay let's look
through this and we find a decision tree
here and
and some big decision tree and we get to
this one little point
well it says here you know you didn't
pay this furniture bill back in 2018.
you know if if only you'd have paid that
furniture bill
like we would be able to give you the
loan right but the truth isn't that
simple like it's actually buried all
throughout
yeah throughout the decision tree right
with so many contributing points
yeah i think uh like this chapter that
you referenced uh was about like
kind of from the social view or the
human view what what people like or
prefer as explanations um and the whole
chapter is based on um i forgot the
title of the paper it's
like from miller um about like
what we can learn from the social
sciences about what a good explanation
is and
was like a paper where i learned a lot
and it was super interesting also to see
how like what people think are good
explanation as you mentioned they should
be contrastive they should be short
but they should also confirm to some
prior knowledge that the people have
um and i mean like objectively a lot of
those things might not
like you wouldn't say these are good
explanations in some sense like
maybe um maybe it's not good to give an
explanation that fits with
a priori knowledge um because it's not
the correct one maybe
so um was quite interesting to to learn
and to
to think about like what's the human
side of it that's a very cool part of
your book i thought the fact that
it's actually quite interesting thinking
about what we really want out of an
explanation
remember first of all looking at you
know sharp values that are very fair and
will distribute the blame
equally amongst all the different
relevant features and then you turn to
something else like
you know um selective interpretations
that
in a way are way less good because
they're kind of arbitrary they'll just
select a few
a few a subset of the features and give
them all the blame but then it turns out
that apparently that's what people
actually want as a useful
interpretable explanation yeah so as i
see there's like many
many dimensions of explainability or
like what what
can be a good explanation and and one of
these dimensions is maybe sparsity that
you have a short explanation with just a
few facts
um that's something that people prefer
maybe um
but this might be in conflict with other
dimensions of a good explanation
which should be maybe that uh all causes
should be addressed by the explanation
that
play some role at least um but this is
of course in conflict with sparsity
if you want this full attribution like
you get with shapley values for example
um so i that's why i also think there's
not like just one correct explanation
but there's like many attributes or many
dimensions on which you can judge
explanations
yeah i think this is one of the problems
because even machine learning is really
difficult right because
we use benchmarks and benchmarks are
just something that people have come up
with but you you say in your
you know you talk about one of the
problems being that there's no
definition of
iml methods to start with but at least
in machine learning methods we have
ground truth
which is which is significantly better
in in a way but um if we
if we can't quantify how good an
explanation is then
where are we really because you talk
about a kind of taxonomy of
interpretability methods right you say
that there are
objective evaluations like sparsity and
interaction strength and fidelity
um and humid human centered evaluations
you know which might come from domain
experts or lay people
so i suppose you're just hitting
straight on the fact that this is
actually
quite nebulous isn't it yeah so yeah
so in some sense like there's this big
criticism so okay this is not
scientific or not well defined at least
what interpretability is
how can we even do research in this area
um
but i i have a better more relaxed view
i mean otherwise i should have stopped
writing the book uh
before i really started um so i kind of
see like this
or this endeavor of giving
interpretability or bringing
interpretability
to machine learning it's more like a
first of all it's just a
keyword so it's it kind of bundles all
the methods together
that kind of aim to reduce this high
dimensional function
to something well mostly it's something
in a lower dimension so we kind of just
do this mapping something gets lost in a
way this is fine
and it's i think part of science to find
out like oh
too yeah some part of analysis to find
out what part gets lost so when you for
example look at uh
just um some feature importance values
for example
of course it's a summary of your model
and a lot of information gets lost
but but i still think um it's it's
useful to have
obviously so many people use it but it's
useful to have these uh
tools and we just have to understand um
what they do
and how to interpret the results so how
do you interpret
when like the future pardons a zero of a
feature
could that be quite dangerous though
because you gave the example of random
forests when you have
a lot of shared information between the
features
it would actually tell you that these
correlated features have a higher
feature importance than
you might otherwise expect so does this
imply that we need to
have very detailed knowledge of how we
should how we should use this
information that we get from iml methods
yeah so it's also kind of the direction
in which i write papers like this
pitfalls
um to avoid and stuff like this so i i
think
so these are just tools so they they do
something with the model they kind of
distill some
knowledge um so for example for feature
importance
you kind of uh measure how well does
your model perform
and then you measure again after you uh
shuffled one of the features
and and then then you get something out
of it so then we can ask the question is
this
interpretable or not and it's kind of
well not so relevant the question
because you just have to understand what
what happens when you
shuffle feature and oneness for example
you kind of break the association
between the feature and
the prediction because now it doesn't
carry the information about the target
anymore
because you're shuffling randomly in
your model
so you kind of this this feature
importance now measures
how much performance you lose because of
this break of information
but then you also when you think about
this method and want to use it you also
have to understand that
the shuffling for example breaks also
association with your other data
like the features in your data so this
is a limitation of the method and
what i think is needed is that we
understand
in which way these methods break or
which
scenarios we're allowed to use them or
how we are allowed to interpret them
and i think the situation is kind of
similar to
statistics where you have these models
and and then you interpret like the
coefficients of your models you still
like have to learn how you're doing the
interpretation
what are the assumptions that have to be
met that you're allowed to do this
interpretation
and i i think it's we're in a similar
similar situation here
with interpretability of machine
learning and i'm glad you mentioned
sort of the old school linear models as
well as dimensionality in this thread
because you make a very good point in
the book which is
look even these so-called intrinsically
interpretable models
are only interpretable up to a certain
dimensionality and you know i have i
have tons of experience with
with multi-linear regression right and
and i can guarantee that beyond
a very small number of dimensions those
coefficients are not interpretable
because it starts to play a bunch of
games where it's inflating one
coefficient
and another because their difference is
important and
you know whatever else is happening a
lot of correlated structures are all
essentially getting compressed
into this small number of small number
of weights right
and so as the dimensionality goes up i
would say like no model
is is intrinsically interpretable same
can be said of
decision trees like anybody who's looked
at a decision tree that's come from real
data
you're going to find out it's not
interpretable it's like oh look at this
you know market capitalization
matters oh and it matters over here too
and down here
and actually i have to go through five
checks on market capitalization before i
get down to this decision
yeah and maybe the features aren't that
intuitive either and then you have to
kind of like mentally stack up like
until you get to the decision
like five uh decisions and then you have
a very complex
rule that that led you to the prediction
um yeah so i agree that um there's
it's not like i mean i have i have this
distinction a book like interpretive
models and
not so interpretable models um but it's
as you say it's like a gray like it's a
scale really
people could definitely over hype how
interpretable these white box models are
right
whether it's linear models i'm a i've
worked with many physicists
who have had guidelines that you should
only ever use
models like a decision tree because it's
possible in theory to write down
on a piece of paper exactly how the
decision is made right you can
trace every decision but that's never
actually useful in practice
since when have you ever looked at a
decision to be fitted to data that's
any complexity and the fact that in
theory it's possible to go and examine
how it works yeah it's completely
irrelevant in practice isn't it yeah
i mean it can be useful to have like a
short decision tree and sometimes
it but in practice it will not like give
you probably the best predictions
um but it might be useful sometimes to
shorten it artificially so even like
you're throwing your weights and some
predictive accuracy
um but you shorten it so you understand
that somehow it's manageable you can
have a look at it
and and see what's going on
well there's also you know the other
issue is that as i was looking through a
lot of the methods that you describe
and you survey in your book you know
some of them
are not simple i mean if you start
looking at partial dependency plots and
trying to explain what those are i mean
you know you have to almost have a deep
mathematical knowledge really to
appreciate them in the first place
so i'm wondering at what point we're
just developing
complex math models to explain complex
math models and we really haven't you
know made much progress
along the interpretability axis
yeah yeah it's true it's also like the
criticism to like um
so you have something you don't
understand and you explain it with
something you don't understand
i think some methods are complex um but
for some
at least there's some intuition how they
work for partially penance plot is
kind of your this intuition that you do
some intervention on your
intervention on your data so you replace
all your
um like for one feature you replace all
the values with
one fixed value and kind of look at the
average
prediction that you get afterwards and
do this for a lot of points and then you
connect the points and you have this
curve so
kind of gives you the expected change um
over
the feature range maybe there was
already a bit complex i don't know
um maybe i'm too deep into the method
already
um but yeah of course it's it's
something additional
people have to learn or if they agree to
use it of course
could i get a quick take from you on
saliency maps as an example because
you said in one of your youtube videos
that saliency maps are glorified edge
detectors they are not good explanations
at all and
i've noticed now that many machine
learning platform providers are building
these kind of
saliency maps into their models you know
into their platforms
and then it becomes a kind of box
ticking exercise where you can say okay
well yeah we've done
interpretability now that's all you need
to know and that really is quite a false
sense of security isn't it
it's funny you mentioned the saliency
maps because i'm
writing a book chapter about it and
actually i'm
i'm i wanted to publish it today maybe i
will or at least in the next few days
um it has been a long time in the making
and it was very very frustrating like by
far the most frustrating chapter to
write
number one reason is because there's so
many methods out there
uh reason number two is i i can't charge
freely or
if they work and it seems like they
mostly don't
or it's it's still unclear like how you
say
you would judge that they work so
they're like dozens of these
like integrated gradients gradients
deconfinet
deep tailor decomposition layer wise
relevance propagation in 10 variants
so and then i mean you in the end you
when you apply these methods on
they're also like for image
classification and you get these nice
looking images and
some areas are highlighted some are not
sometimes you can say okay this doesn't
make sense at all
um but if if it kind of makes sense then
you maybe would be inclined to trust the
method
um but then there's this uh paper which
is called um sanity checks for saliency
maps
and they kind of found out that the the
most of the methods are very similar to
edge detectors
meaning that they are kind of
insensitive to the model and the data
which is very bad of course
well if you change the model the
explanation should obviously change
um could you expand on that a little bit
so you said it wasn't really a
reflection of the model or the data but
what would a perfect saliency map look
like well
i don't know myself actually so i mean
the the idea is
that you so the basic idea of most of
these methods is that you
you have your class prediction or your
class score and you want to
back propagate it not you want to back
propagate it to the original image so
you look at the gradient
um with respect to your input pixels and
it's
there's no not one way to do this but
then many different ways
so that's also why we have so many
different methods and then they
highlight which pixel were
relevant for the classification um
but yeah they these these methods they
have like a lot of
like issues for example there's the
issue of saturation for example because
of the
real unit where you have flat parts of
the gradient so if you pass
the gradient through that then your
method would say that
some some neuron might not be important
at all
and there's a lot of these little issues
that these methods have
um yeah so but but back to your question
like i think that's also an issue that i
don't wouldn't know how to answer it i
mean obviously it should be some area
that
should be highlighted on this aliens map
that was important for the
for the neural network um but then again
i don't know how the network decides so
i couldn't
like if i see an image i couldn't like
highlight the part
i mean i could highlight the part or i
think the network should look
but then again i mean lots of papers
like the clever hands paper which
saw like the revealed that there are
some
sometimes it would look at watermarks on
on the photo
um so these are like these things that
we just don't know uh
what the neural network places this on
if i could take a stab at that answer
i'd
for one i think just the idea of quote a
saliency map is a problem like there
isn't one
map of the importance of the pixels it's
like they're they're operating on
multiple
multiple dimensions or at least sort of
multiple feature sets it's like if you
ask me to tell
you know why is this image a dog you
know well for one thing
it's it's the overall shape you know it
has four legs and you know two ears
sticking out over here that's one
saliency another is that it's it's got a
certain color
you know and it's coat and that's that's
a different concept of what sailing
and another is that there's a frisbee
flying at it and its mouth is open and
it's about to catch it and i know
dogs do that so they're kind of you know
when your mind analyzes an
image it breaks it down into this many
large scale kind of structural features
and i think that gets completely lost
and most of the approaches to saliency
maps
this is a really important point
actually because
if you're just looking at the pixels on
this kind of 2d
planar manifold that's only a very it is
quite literally a surface view
and i think christoph you said that
there are all sorts of causal structures
and
even in the model itself right there are
these entangled neurons and surely
that's giving me more
insight into what's actually happening
just seeing a bunch of pixels
and the other thing is that these models
that they are completely lacking in
robustness so probably if you changed a
few of the wrong pixels your saliency
map has just
got completely broken right yeah so um
but in in that
vein some of these uh feature
visualization techniques you know like
the deep dream type stuff
maybe maybe that's a better way of of um
interpreting these models
yeah um so like for the one point you
mentioned about that was early example
so there's also
a paper i forgot the title again um
which
manipulated neural networks so they
would give the same
prediction for all the images but
different explanation like different
saliency maps so
this is perfectly possible to create
different explanations
um for these saliency maps um but but
keeping the model
like at least for the predictions the
same there's another criticism you can
throw at saliency maps where they
they can be quite deceiving you think
they're useful and then they turn out
not to be useful there's a classic
example of looking at
you know comparing a dog to a wolf and
sometimes you see it's looking at the
snow in the background and that's
helpful
sometimes it highlights the animal and
you think okay i understand it's looking
at the face that's why it thinks it's a
dog because it's seen their face
and then you look at the predicted class
for something else like you know
a cat or a frisbee or a house or a boat
and it highlights their face as well
so this agency map for all these
different classes looks the same
and when you realize that you realize
this this agency map
hasn't actually told you anything about
why it's gone for one class versus the
other all it's said is that it has
highlighted the thing in the middle of
the picture
yeah i think that's especially also when
when you look at images here like
we're very good at with images like
we're very quick to see what's happening
on a scene and such
so we i think we're also very quick to
make judgments oh yeah this makes sense
this doesn't make sense
it's more difficult to interpret like if
you have like a graph and there's like
things going on inside you have to
like now understand what a method does
and stuff like this but for a
image like a heat map i have this area
as highlight makes sense
um case closed um i i like the method
yeah and that gets exactly back to the
deceptively
deceptively good explanations problem
and explaining
complex things with complex things we
don't understand and so i
i think a lot of people if they looked
at it and again one of the points of
this interpretability is really the
social aspects of it right like
being able to convince people to be at
ease with machine learning models or to
accept
the results of of a machine learned you
know decision process
and i think if somebody looks at an
image of a dog you know they have no
problem understanding that
but if you showed them a bunch of
salience maps or or any of the other
sort of uh you know feature projections
if you will
like you said it takes a lot of deep
understanding to understand those
words the image is kind of immediately
obvious
i think two of the main themes that you
touch on is we'll we'll get to the
to the probabilistic stuff the the
judeo-pearl stuff in in a minute but
i think the main issue that you point
out is feature dependence
okay and and you say that when you have
feature dependence it makes attribution
and extrapolation problematic
so a dependence just means that you've
got correlated or shared information
between your features right
so you say that in feature permutation
methods um
these things basically break everything
when you have the shared information
and the extrapolated data points are no
longer in the distribution
and you say that there are conditional
permutation schemes you know that try
and and maintain that joint distribution
but
those things sometimes make it even
worse right so do you think that's one
of the most important things that people
should think about when using iml
methods yeah
at least so um that's that's a at least
like a very
um deep issue i would say uh which is
inherent in
in most of the model agnostic methods
where you
manipulate your data see what how the
model prediction changes and then
create your explanations out of this
sort of select the shuttle value
line partially penance plot feature
importance they all work with this
mechanism of
manipulation of the data prediction and
then kind of aggregating the results
and most manipulations um happen in
isolation so that you
for example um when you
for feature importance you can meet one
of the features as i like said
sometime before um and then
well you break the situation of the
target but also a few other features
but similar things happen if you use
limes or you
kind of replace parts of your image but
then again you also have to replace it
with something like
which is i think in line the default is
with just a gray image
and then of course it's not a like it's
outside of your data distribution
suddenly because
your network was not confronted with
like these patchy
images before they had like just normal
photographs usually
and depends on your neural network but
um you certainly didn't train it on
on images where parts were grayed out so
it's pretty unclear what
the model should predict and what will
predict at this point
but but you you use these images to
create your data set like you send it
for the neural network you get
predictions and
you kind of aggregate from this your
explanation
but but you left your data distribution
and and your model can do anything
uh then and the hope is that it doesn't
do anything crazy but
yeah you don't know like it like a
simple example
from the medical field would be that you
know height and weight
are highly correlated right and
and on the other hand sort of the ratio
or some relationship between your
your weight to your height that actually
has very important
medical consequences right that's that's
the measure of of health
and so if i were to sit there and just
permute say the height index
and create a whole bunch of people that
had all these bizarre combinations of
of height and weight you know first of
all those don't even probably exist in
the data set and the ones that do exist
in the data set
probably had some medical issues right
yeah
well you actually gave a similar example
i think you gave the example kristoff of
a baby that earns a hundred thousand
dollars a year which is
which is insane but when you talk about
something like lime
maybe that's different because the cnn
what you know
it shines a flashlight over the input
space and it's an
it's a kind of local method so in some
sense you could argue that it doesn't
matter that you've grayed out all this
other stuff because
if the model was sufficiently well
trained in the first place it should
hopefully learn to ignore the background
or is that just wishful thinking that's
an interesting
thought i i haven't thought about it
because like the property of like um
that you have these filters that just
wonder over the the image here maybe it
would make it more robust for these kind
of um
interventions that we do when we create
these images with lime and sharply
um yeah i haven't thought about it it
could be uh
well we've mentioned all of these ways
in which interpretability methods can go
wrong right how
the model might not be a realistic the
interpretability model might not be a
good
approximation to the actual ml model so
some people a bit
controversially perhaps take the idea
and remember that and say you're just
marking up
completely the wrong tree and you should
give up using interpretability
interpretability methods to explain
these black book boxes
this dish them instead just use an
interpretable model to begin with use a
white box model
i think there's an example from compass
in the us which is that model to predict
reoffending
and i think quite famously there was a
investigative journalists
that tried to interpret this model it
was a
black box model because it's proprietary
right it's a trade secret
and they they fitted a proxy model a
kind of a linear model
and they made a report saying okay we
think your model is racist because it
looks like it's
it's taking race as a factor and then
some further work was done and they came
back and said well actually you've just
used a
uh interpretability model that doesn't
really fit our model very well you've
made some assumptions that don't hold
if you use a different interpretability
model you get a completely different
answer that it doesn't use race at all
as a factor
and so you've got to kind of you've got
to a wrong assumption by using a bad
interpretability model and i think they
were saying that this model
instead you could get just just as good
a model if you're offending with
like three fl statements you know
ditching this massive complex
100 and something features and just use
three fl statements based on i think age
and reoffending
so is that is that what we should do
should we just drop these methods and
start using white boxes instead so i
i mean like one one thing to mention
here is that a white box is very soon
also like a gray or black box
um if you add interactions if you have
many features and so on
but putting that aside um i would agree
with you
in first place like that you say you
should start with like a white box so if
you
start modeling then then then you should
um
consider these first like maybe they
already solved your problem
then it's perfect and you have a model
that is quite i mean
stable it's interpretable um
i think that would be great um but
then i think the next step would be to
see like what like a black box or a
machine learning model
would give you in terms of performance
and then maybe
if you see this the gap is really big
then maybe you can try some feature
engineering
and close the gap maybe from the
interpreter model to the
machine learning model but then you're
probably already infusing some
features that are not so interpretable
or maybe um
if you're using a linear regression
model you're maybe using then splines
and interactions so you're already
moving towards more complex models
usually
um but then if you still have a gap then
i think you have to decide is the gap in
predictive performance
um like worth
changing to a black box model so um i
think that's
your this decision will be different in
many cases
actually relates back to the point you
made on your paper about criticisms of
using
intellectual machinery models some
people leap straight away to using an
overly complex model
and sometimes depending on the situation
sometimes you know a linear model can do
just as well
and have all these advantages it's so
much easier to explain
do you have a philosophy from a high
level here right because
if it if it were a human if it were an
airplane pilot
we don't really understand how the brain
works
right we we were just test the pilot you
got to fly the plane for 10
000 hours and if you don't crash then
we'll let you
fly so we don't really seek to
understand how his or her brain works
but with machine learning models there's
this continuum right so
um if you use these complex black box
models the predictive performance is
usually better but
you're trading off understandability and
assuming those things are completely
mutually exclusive what kind of decision
process do you go through when you
select these models
but by the way with machine learning
right the reason why we use machine
learning is because we don't understand
how to do something explicitly
yeah is that a fair statement um
yeah i would say um when when your data
is
like so high dimensional so complex many
interactions and so on
um that your simple models don't cover
the complex cannot cover the complexity
i think then you need machine learning
would you rather understand exactly how
the plane worked or would you
rather i mean if if i was saying to you
you can go and fly in a plane
would you rather you understood how the
plane worked or would you rather that
the plane was tested
why not both so um
i think we can do both at some to some
degree so
um of course with black box model we
don't exactly understand how they work
um but in comparison to a pilot we can
test them
for free more or less um so because
i mean maybe it's not as good as an
interpreter model
but we still can use a lot of methods to
at least approximate
and and try to understand a few
properties of this model
so i think we are even in a situation
where we don't have
like these complete like aob decisions
but we can have so if if the machine
works much better and it's like really
robustly tested with
lots of different data i would prefer
machine learning model i guess um
but then i would also want to like
people to
to apply all these methods that are
available even if they are not perfect
but still they give you something they
give you some insights
so yeah and i think so tim one answer to
your question is that a lot of people's
response here and kind of demanding
interpretability
and having concerns about machine
learning it all comes down to
generalizability and we've seen through
using machine learning
that it breaks down in ways that we
don't like
like for example sure maybe this soap
dispenser
you know is really great at uh at
dispensing
at dispensing soap you know 87 percent
of the time but it just so happens to
kind of be a
race sensitive soap dispenser and just
doesn't give any soap to people with a
certain skin color
like we've kind of decided as a society
that are that there are certain
generalizations or certain dimensions
along which are our models just have to
perform
and also because a lot of these these
things that break
machine learning models are things that
happen quite
quite regularly in the real world it's
like a pilot
you know a human being pilot flying
around if he looks down at the ground
and sees a hot air balloon with a big
smiley face on it
he's not going to crash the plane he's
just going to be like oh yeah i forgot
about the uh
the hot air balloon contest that's going
on today whereas the machine learning
model if it looks out of camera and see
something with a particular
shape of lightning bolt you know it
might just decide it's time to like
dive for the ground right and crash the
plane like that's sort of what these
adversarial
examples kind of show and i think that's
why people are really
hungering for human understandable
explanations because still to this day
the human brain
is the only agi really that we have
around
yeah but deep learning models that they
they essentially memorize lots and lots
of things and they have this sparse
coding
so in a way it's just like the white box
model even if we use interpretability
methods we could enumerate all of the
things that they are learning
and one of those things might be a
sensitivity or lack of sensitivity to
hot air balloons or smiley faces on
but even if we could enumerate all the
things that they are learning
we wouldn't understand that either in
the same way we don't understand how a
real human's brain works
and i'm not sure whether we should view
a human brain as a computer program and
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing
but um at some i guess what i'm saying
is at some point
we have to accept that we're not going
to understand
totally it's such a it's a good
comparison i think with humans you know
if you're interviewing and you want to
hire let's say a software developer
you tend to set them according interview
you wouldn't think of
taking them into surgery opening up
their brain and trying to find the
neuron that predicts what the next
you know bit of code is going to be and
understanding how that works it's just
why would you do it that way instead you
learn to trust humans by
working with them giving them a test
seeing how they perform in the real
world
i know you know maybe you were asking
too much of a machine learning model if
you want to be able to understand these
complex things in terms of
like a bottom-up white box set of rules
yeah i think what a comparison falls a
bit short is that
that we have the luxury that we can cut
off the
like cut open the brain of a machine
learning model without breaking it
and without hurting it hopefully
and we can do all these try
out all these interpretation methods see
how it behaves under certain situations
and i also would make a distinction
between we understand what's going on
inside
and doing like this kind of sensitivity
analysis
where we just try out what happens in
certain scenarios
um so i would always do that um that we
can
like check like how it behaves
so i mean feature importance here is
basically like a way to see
like how does it behave if we break some
features and then we rank the features
by this
as an importance um we can do it and and
um that's also the big difference
between humans because we can't
test in the same way and you know
shouldn't probably but
i think there's there's one other
difference though which is to do with
the substrate of how neural networks
work i think
if i'm if i'm giving someone a job
interview or something i i mean of
course it's a very
uh valuable process but i'm looking at
their values and i'm looking to try and
understand how they would behave in
different situations and i'm coming up
with lots of illustrative examples
but the difference is with with humans
we have that level of generalization
um we have a kind of guiding taxonomy of
behaviors
which means if i if i know if i have
guiding examples of what a human will do
in certain situations i expect that to
generalize whereas my hypothesis is is
that a deep neural network model
is almost like an infinite number of
rules and there's absolutely no carry
over between the rules
so knowing even some or even most of the
rules
doesn't really tell me about those edge
cases
yeah i would agree that the edge cases
are quite unforeseeable probably i mean
at least we know that they exist like
with adversarial examples so
even if we don't know like exactly what
they would look like or there's even an
infinite amount of
uh i mean there's an infinite amount of
like how you can
change the image to make it like have a
different class so
we know so i think it's important that
we know that these exist at least
yeah i love the point you made though
that we have we have the luxury to do
analysis on these on these boxes because
we can open them up
and that that's another point i'm pretty
sure that you make this in your book as
well which is that
part of this is just scientific inquiry
it's it's like
understanding better how to interpret
and explain
machine learning models will probably
actually contribute to us being able to
construct even better machine learning
models isn't that true
so so you're basically saying that um
also interpretability might help to
to be better at um like create better
machine learning models themselves yeah
like
as we as we develop these
interpretability methods because
in a sense like you point out earlier
there are statistical projections
of kind of behavior of the model and so
like a saliency map you know if we can
if we can kind of use that to learn the
way in which the
the neural networks are behaving it may
it can certainly give rise to intuitions
on ways to alter the model
yeah so i also have seen approaches
where they um
try like kind of fuse also these two two
worlds like
interpretive models or white box models
and black box models so that you try to
to generate features out of the black
box model which you then use
in your on this more understandable
white box model so um i think
this this and and this also like was
using similar techniques
um to which you would use for
interpretability like detecting
interactions for examples
for example so um yeah these can be used
also to to build better models and also
to build better interpretable models
the other and i'll make one last point
here which is another
social good that can come out of
interpretability is
imagine we've got you know an ml model
that's not trying to make any decisions
but it's just trying to figure out
what leads to happiness and success in
life you know and so we analyze a whole
bunch of data and we find out well
it's really important if you graduate
from high school and it's really
important if you
you know don't have children before
you're married and you know all these
other factors if we can dive in and kind
of isolate those factors
it actually allows people to have some
guidance on
oh look we've had this machine learning
model that's analyzed a bunch of data
and it actually has some
some understandable recommendations for
how to lead a healthier life or a better
life or whatever
yeah i think this very good example were
the fact that you have a prediction
model doesn't solve your problem
um so actually it's just a means to um
to some other goal in this case
understanding like what are the factors
for happiness
and one example i am from a friend who
worked at a telecom company
and they built like a churn prediction
model um
to see like who who will quit the
telecom contract
um and then they started like
the the ones with the highest likelihood
they started sending out emails hey
maybe offering them a better deal but
actually the outward card was that um
well they they when they once they wrote
to the customers they
well left uh and quit that contract so
it's kind of had like so this is a case
where the prediction model actually
works
but then people leave in this case
probably because they realized oh i
have this contract
still going on time to quit now
um so if you knew the reasons why
they are likely to turn then you could
like better select
like um when you write some email or
maybe some other campaign or when maybe
not to write anything at all
yeah right now um christoph you have a
background in stats
which means you mean you like connor as
well we take an incredibly dim view of
machine learning and
you wonder how is it possible for us to
be stabbing in the dark like this but
you know you said that we need to be
more rigorous and there's
no quantification of uncertainty with
the current iml methods and i
i suspect you might be working on some
methods behind the scenes on this but
you know when you have models and
explanations which are computed from
data
they are subject to uncertainty and
that's just not um modeled at all at the
moment right so we need to be making
some distributional
and structural assumptions that we're
not making now and you point out that
there's this phenomenon of p
hacking which is a huge problem in the
natural sciences which hasn't quite made
its way to iml methods yet but probably
will do
yeah so yeah so the i think
and in statistics we're really good at
quantifying uncertainty i mean
this also has some darker sides with
like the p hacking and so on
but i i still would say it's better to
have um
not only just one number or one
explanation but also have the
distribution
to do of this explanation or this number
and to quantify what uncertainties
behind computing this number
so when you have a linear model then you
get
some coefficient which you interpret in
the end but usually you don't
just interpret the coefficient but you
look at the confidence intervals
but we don't do it at the moment for uh
interpretability so
you maybe get the saliency maps but how
certain are you
about maybe it's a bad example because
we dumped so much on it um but if you
have like a feature importance value and
you get some result
how like what's the range actually like
how much variance is behind it
if i were to use slightly different data
or refit my model again
how similar would the number be and i
think that's something that
will or should come to interpretability
as well
it's funny how when we come to machine
learning it's almost like open season
and forgetting everything you know about
maths and stats
you throw it all out the window get so
excited about these algorithms right
like one example is
if you take a if you were fitting a
model to predict something that was
unlikely i don't know maybe it was like
a
covert test for example and then if you
know the prevalence of covert you get it
back you kind of know what the false
positive rate is going to be
and so you notice that you think it's
the multiple comparison issue right you
know that you're expecting a certain
level of false positives
when it comes to doing something like
feature importance or looking at
interpretability from a thousand
features and then five come through is
really really important
yeah yeah you mentioned sometimes we
just forget that multiple comparison
issue forget the fact that probably
these five are going to be
completely false positives and probably
completely meaningless yeah i agree um
especially if you have like these high
dimensionality features
and for the record i have to say i mean
there are already approaches so
especially for future importance um
because there's like a huge community in
random forests for example
and they thought a lot about these
issues and their tests for this and
stuff like it
um but for the rest of interpretability
i think it could gain a lot
um thinking more about i mean this is
very simple stuff
like uh multiple comparisons uh
quantifying uncertainty doesn't stuff
like statisticians think like a long
time already
about it um and i mean if you even if
you leave the area of interpretability
and look at the benchmarks
so even like if you have like accuracy
like a table and you see accuracies in
it
but there's no uh variance attached to
it then it should be like suspicious of
it but because if you just retrain your
neural network with a different seed you
might end up with a different accuracy
in the end
so and if you say want to say a method
is better than another method
you want to quantify uh how
large ranges of uncertainty do you i
mean there are a lot of things like the
choice of data
choice of splitting points and training
and test data weight initialization and
so on
so i think a lot of that this rigor from
statistics
uh could help um the machine learning
community and
and machine link science to become
better yeah but let's let's never forget
this uh
quite quite well-known saying which is
there are three kinds of lies
lies damned lies and statistics
so you know that that's a lot of what's
going on right is is
you know fundamentally whenever we go
measure data and we have a model
what we're actually able to extract from
that data and
and the model is inherently
probabilistic
it's a probability distribution right at
the end of the day
and we get into trouble any time we try
to take that probability distribution
and project it to numbers i.e statistics
like as soon as we start trying to
to generate and it doesn't matter
whether it's it's a mean
plus a confidence interval or whatever
the fact is we're throwing away
information the totality of the
information sitting there in that weird
multi-modal you know spread out
distribution
right and then we we find some way to
simplify it and project it down to a set
of numbers
we've got a problem like that's and if
you forget that that's happening if you
forget that you're throwing away all
this information i think the
you know the tendency to do that isn't
just simplification
it's that oftentimes we have to use
these probabilistic
things to reach a decision and as soon
as we get to the point where look i've
got to choose either to go left or right
give the loan or not give the loan as
soon as we get down to some point
where we have to make a concrete
decision we're forced
you know we're forced to project it
right but
along the way it's important not to lose
sight of the fact that we're throwing
away information
fantastic well um and by the way uh you
also said something interesting a minute
ago christoph which is about
at least in most machine learning
algorithms if you change the random seed
you know that there's
enough stability there that it still
gives you roughly the the same model
every time but in reinforcement learning
uh if you change the random seed the
entire thing is
is completely broken but um but yeah
what keith was saying about this this um
this information and structure and
models i think that's really interesting
because people have said with
reinforcement learning you can actually
learn causal factors right but that's
not
really true you're interacting with a
system but what you're learning is is a
surface representation of causal factors
so you might learn that
there's a causal factor between like a
hose
putting out fire but it wouldn't
actually learn that it was the water
that put out you know there was a causal
relationship between the water and the
fire
and this is the case with so many of our
models as we were saying earlier there's
just a surface representation which
doesn't actually represent the reality
of our world at all
but this brings me on to the next point
because you have a real problem with
causal interpretations of some of these
iml metrics right and you
you say that models well the goal of
models is that they should reflect
the causal structure right this is what
we want to do in science but most
statistical learning just reflects these
surface
feature correlations they don't even
scratch the surface of what we want
so what are we going to do right are you
doing some work in this field to help us
out here and and why are people making
these
fallacious interpretations yeah so i'm
not
not working on anything causality
related at the moment
yeah but about about causality i mean i
kind of like um i studied statistics
bachelor and master and and
zero i mean the only
time we were talked about causality was
when i heard the sentence
correlation does not imply causality
that
was really about it so um i think it's
like really um yeah should be taught a
lot more like how to think about
causality like it's just super simple
things like
you should include confounders or like
what types of features if you include
them in the model
um like uh destroy your causal
interpretation of another features
these are not super difficult things so
um there you don't have to
like learn any like difficult frameworks
to work with or or
read like causality books on it that's
like
super simple um yeah rules of thumb for
your features even
um yeah and i think you also have to
decide um or distinguish between
um like what's the goal of your model do
you want an
uh a causal interpretation um
or do you want to like because in a
sense um you have to
also distinguish between two levels you
have the real world level
and the model level i mean once you use
features for the model they are
causal for the moderate prediction of
course because you designed it that way
and the question is when you are you
allowed to go to the real world level
where you say
okay this um the future importance that
i see here also the feature dependence
plot that i see is also causal um
or and may interpret it as a cause and
or as a causal effect also for for the
real world
and i i think that also depends like if
you need this interpretation and if you
do scientific
modeling for example then you probably
want it
um but there can also be good reasons to
include non-causal features into your
model
if your goal is really just prediction
and and some feature might help you
with a good prediction um but it might
not be causal at all
yes but the problem is when we're using
these deep learning models
they they will learn a structure which
probably has no
relationship to the real world
whatsoever but um i think causal
um factors do generalize much better
there's the example of
um i don't know with car crashes right
male testosterone levels is a causal
factor so that will probably
generalize to other locations where you
didn't train your data on but
unfortunately models don't really do
that well but
so just real quickly on that tim like
the only reason that we know
testosterone is a causal factor
is is not from that data set it's from a
bunch of mechanistic
you know scientific research in biology
and
and elsewhere so you know i
i'm kind of wondering how it would be
nice if at least
machine learning methods could indicate
that there may be the possibility of a
causal structure so just looking for
underlying hidden structures um that
that
you know that are more generalizable
that could explain large pieces of the
of the data and give kind of a list of
hey there might be a causal factor here
like go investigate it but on on that
there's a difference between a causal
factor and a causal structure
i think that the challenge is that we
don't have enough fidelity in the
structure
that bingo by the way is doing some
interesting work on this using data
driven approaches to um you know learn
causal factors
but it's the structure of the factor
graph which i think is the important
thing
i mean this is one of the most
interesting parts i think of machine
learning actually trying to learn
causation from a data set which you can
do right things like beta networks where
you specify all your variables you
connect these nodes with edges
and you can try to learn the optimal
structure like the simplest structure
and that sometimes
turns out to be the real life causal
effect if you do as well
but the difference is you as a human you
you know the causal structure and you've
you've created
that that graph so it's not learned
you've created it
you can learn these things from data
right you can actually you can search
over the set of all possible graphs all
the possible edges
and you have a bit of a loss function
you try to find a graph that fits the
data well so it's got enough edges
but it's not too complex you're not
relating everything to everything
and so just from data without any human
input with structure learning
you can sometimes get a model that kind
of out of nothing
will give you the cause relationships
sometimes there is redundancy right
because
a graph that says a implies causes b
equals a c
that's identical to c causes b causes a
right but even then with structure
learning you
you've got this adjacency matrix and all
of those nodes you've already come up
with a priory so
what you want to learn is what the nodes
are themselves right
yeah i think like what connor mentioned
just also motor setting where you have
well-defined features and i think what
tim
referred to was more like the you don't
even know what the features are like if
you
have a convolutional neural network and
and like what's an object
um what what is a feature that like is
disentangled also from other
objects um so i think also there is the
big
issue that you have this entanglement
between concepts that
i don't know that the frisbee is always
with uh
on the same image as a as a dog so um
maybe that the the neural network can't
even separate these two things then
because they are
too entangled in the data set to even
discover the structure
that that is really underlying the real
world in this case
that's a fascinating point actually
because one of the reasons why there's
no easy solution to adversarial examples
is because
you learn these these non-robust
features and you might just think to
yourself well
um fur is a low magnitude feature it's
really easy just to kind of create fur
on anything and for the neural network
into thinking it's a cat
and you just say well this is obvious
right you just create some rules to say
well if it's
if it's not an animal and fur then
ignore the fur
but actually the features are entangled
in this complex neural network so you
can't do that
but i i wanted to move the discussion on
a bit so you said that there are some
really interesting challenges ahead in
in iml
and what's fascinating is you start
talking about the process so you say
that the setting of machine learning is
too static it doesn't reflect how these
models are used in reality
and models are embedded in a process or
a product or even complex people
interactions
and i love this right because i talk
about ml devops and machine learning
models in isolation are irrelevant
it's the people and the process that's
where the complexity is even with
intelligence itself it's a process right
you know intelligence is the interaction
between a brain a body and an
environment
and you know within the context of this
process you know we've got all of this
rich information that we could be
bringing in from other disciplines and
you're saying we should bring in compsci
and stats folks and
we should be uh bringing in
psychologists and social scientists
and we need to also have
interpretability at a higher level at
the institutional level right or at the
society level
so when you kind of broaden the
discussion out a little bit i think it
adds a nice bit of flavor
yeah so it's very as especially as a
scientist it's so convenient to just
have this fixed model a fixed data set
and then
you just geek out and invent all these
methods and so on
but reality is that that you use the
method some
someplace and then it interacts with uh
the institution it's built with the
developers it's built by
with the people it affects and my
favorite example there is
when you have this closed loop where um
your model makes predictions and these
predictions generate
the next generations data so
for the next generation of the model it
produces the data so
um there's this example of um the rent
index where you have this model that
tells you how much rent you should like
pay
for a certain kind of apartment and so
on and and this is actually like
um legally binding so if you
land if you're a landlord you you have
to accept kind of the range that is
outputted by the model
which also means that um the data that
is produced so the new flats that are
rented out in your apartments
um they all have to fit the model kind
of
and then but then you use this data
again to train your model so you have
this
very weird feedback loop and right um
i think it's also difficult to wrap your
head around it and
understand the implications of it
that that same thing a very similar feed
the feedback
loop was a fear in the
you know in our algo shambles video
about the uk
testing since i couldn't conduct the the
uh
what was it the a level test right tim
they they built some some models around
that
and so it would do things like well you
know if this school historically never
had anyone in this grade bucket then
we're not going to assign anyone
to that great bucket in that school and
so sort of the self-perpetuating
you know feedback loop we were reading
through a lot of your work
and you i mean i'm just going to hit
this point head on
you don't really talk that much about ai
ethics and
you know that there's the f word which
is the fairness word and and i don't i
don't recall you ever using that word
and is that something that you've
deliberately shied away from
um yeah i just like
um define it as outside of the scope
like
to talk or to to i don't know talk about
ethic so
um fairness metrics or so on because i
think that's a really big field on its
own and i
just don't know as much like about all
these um things so i know a little bit
like about the fairness metrics that
they're out there
um i also think i mean they're kind of
like research-wise a little bit
overlapping but more or less separate
fields i think interpretability and
fairness
um but of course they have some
commonalities that i mean
when you kind of to for fairness you
have to look
it's not necessarily inside the model
but you have to study how the model
behaves
and that's kind of the connection to
interpretability i would say
yeah well we're yeah where i see the
connection is
work like yours is helping to build the
tool set that will
allow people to apply human
you know intuition and ethics and
evaluations to machine learning because
at the end of the day a lot of these are
human moral judgments or ethical
judgments
and it's important that people be happy
with them because
you know we have to have the population
as a whole understand and accept and be
able to move forward
with the increasing role that machine
learning is having in our lives
and building that tool set is necessary
so it's like you said very early in this
talk
you know what do we do just stick our
heads in the sand and ignore it and just
accept
machine learning models are going to do
whatever they do as long as they fly the
plane or you know don't kill too many
people
we're okay like i don't think that's
gonna work like we have to build the
tool set
that you're talking about and continue
this process of exploring
how to better explain and interpret ml
models so that
human beings can have that oversight
because it's the only thing that's going
to
give us comfort really as a society i
suppose the reason i segway to this is
we were just talking about
the process and you you mentioned some
of these feedback loops because we can
have a very superficial discussion you
could say well
we need to be able to represent reality
better than we do and we have a whole
tool set here to
identify sources of bias or or you know
lack of robustness etcetera and models
but
it's so much more complex than that
because these models are used
in a very complex process and you get
these very very
complex dynamics emerging as a result of
that and i think we're only really just
scratching the surface of understanding
those dynamics
yeah i think so too as i said i think
in science it's always very easy to to
study things in isolation
like study one type of model study one
type of adjustment for a deep neural
network
and um hopefully we will see more work
emerge on this i i think i've never read
a paper like
um i mean of course discuss the
implications but really
like analyze like what happens in terms
of the data
and the model um when you have like
multiple generations for example of a
model and how it changes over time
but this thing i mean to study those
things also means that you have to
wait for a long time and until you have
these dynamics
and i think in many cases it's just
starting that we use these models more
extensively
in our daily life i have a question is
is anyone because look interpretability
metrics whatever they are saliency maps
and you know
could be a partial dependency plots
whatever you could actually build in
some requirements of those into the
objective functions when you go to train
models so for example
i'm just going to come up with a crazy
idea i have no idea if this is relevant
at all but somebody could say look
i want all my saliency maps to be you
know
sets of of uh bezier curves or something
like that like they have to have a
certain smoothness
property and you could actually put that
as a constraint
in the objective function has anybody
tried anything like that yeah
there are approaches so i saw on paper
they um added some
um some parts to their objective
function so that
um when you create line explanations
with line that they were most
more stable and there are a lot of
things like and
for neural networks you have
disentanglement that you try
um that the feature maps or
the nodes learn disentangled concepts
um they're ways to introduce like
monotonicity
so that the feature can always go and
the effect of a feature can always
be in one direction not to like zigzag
around so that there are approaches to
do this to
um like have
like interpretability constraints in
your modeling yeah
yeah because i was just thinking this
can go back to conor you know conor was
saying earlier on why don't we just
create white box models
maybe we can use if the definition to a
human being of white box is that it's
interpretable and understandable
if we can build into the objective
functions when we're actually training
the network that
has these properties then we'll actually
be helping to create
more white box you know models even if
they are complex
that's definitely an option but i think
the
issue remains the same that you with
it's similar to a white box model i mean
you make some trade-offs
in the end you have to make the judgment
whether
so when you put more constraints i mean
you it can
actually also help the model of course
that if you i mean if you have some
inductive biases also
um which um which you infuse into the
model
which help of predicting or be more more
stable
um but sometimes you make maybe also a
trade-off
with accuracy and you just have to like
in the end you have this
um yeah this set of models were some
more accurate some um better in this one
interpretability dimension the other is
uh cheaper to deploy and
you then you have this so this kind of
going into the direction of like
automatic machine learning
and it you don't get like just the best
uh performing one but you have
this pareto set like well so we have
multiple objectives that you want to hit
and then there's not one model that is
works best but you have a set of models
that
that have different trade-offs between
these objectives and then you have to
decide
um what is the trade-off that you want
to do
or that you want to make sense
well i guess there's no getting away
from it is there the interpretability
just going to get more important and
more important i think you mentioned
christoph that you know we've had linear
models for hundreds of years
and then there's been this big explosion
and deep learning and then
what do you say about 2016 to 2018
that's when interpretabilities really
kicked off
i what do you think do you think where
is it going are we just going to get
more and more attention paid to this
area um i i i don't know if you can get
more than
than this i don't know um yeah but i
think it's at least here to stay
and i um yeah i think it's important i
mean it has been important before but um
of course with like the the push from
deep learning especially and
um that it just became more clear to a
lot of people that we need
interpretability in some sense at least
um
yeah of course people have attempted it
before and
worked on it before and it's just more
urgent now
i really like the bet in your book
talking about what's what's changed
recently how
interpretability is coming together as a
field you know with this a
unification so you know in physics we
love a big unification when you take all
these different things in the past and
say
oh they're all just part of this one big
framework and it was
shap that shot paper was amazing wasn't
it saying things like
lime deep lift layer wise propagation
sharply
ah forget all them they're all special
cases of these
additive feature attribution methods and
we can prove that this is the only one
that's
theoretically valid because it has these
properties of symmetry it's got
the stamina property so you know
everything that's been done before
inadeptability well they're all in our
framework now and shafty values are the
way forward
yeah they're quite uh quite famous the
shadowy values
yeah would you believe them then i mean
i guess in their paper they're kind of
they kind of disagree with lima but
don't they they say well lime is a
count of this but they're going to be
breaking our properties of efficiency
and symmetry so
lyme is using the wrong weights right
they should be using this kernel shaft
weights rather than the line weights
yeah i think that's just a different
approach also to think about it i mean
you don't maybe you don't i think i
think the properties are quite
attractive or meaningful at least um but
also also the lime approach i i'm very
critical about lime because it um
i think it's difficult to have the
correct
or to know like how to parameterize your
uh
your local models so i
i think i'm a bit more of a fan of
shapley values
because of the theoretical properties it
comes with
are you talking about that distance
measure in line where you have to be
able to quantify
how far away is the parameters like the
kernel width
yeah which is set to 0.75
in the code i think also i just looked
it up and i mean it's
it's a very difficult question it goes
to the heart of inter like
what's local um because like
i mean you have this this kernel that
decides like how much you weight
all the data points around the point you
want to explain
and and like how how big is this area i
think this is
very dependent on your model and your
data and there's no answer no easy
answer to how to set it
yeah or even more generally than that
there's this whole notion of
what does it mean to have a local
interpretation method in
you know on text or vision so in
envision there's this super pixel
concept which is something that seems to
make intuitive sense but but does it
you know when you create all of these
different maskings of different parts of
the input space but um
with shapley values as well they they
are a beautiful
a beautiful technique especially because
the the values are quite meaningful
but if you have shared information
between the features i mean connor and i
were talking about this for example you
you
if you had the same model where you were
predicting someone's
income and you put their i don't know
let's say you had salary in the model
twice
then the sharply value would be divided
between the two
duplicate fields right so there just
seems to be so much esoterica in these
iml methods right are we expected to
know all of this stuff
yeah i i think i mean that's why i wrote
the book um to
capture these things that you have to
know these these uh
disadvantages of the methods where i try
to be very honest i mean
because i'm not too invested in them but
yeah i think
the that's with all tools that we
usually have
um also with statistics and so on you
you have to know
like um these like as you mentioned this
if you have salary twice and it will
just i mean depends also on what your
model does if it just picks one of the
salary features
or if it itself uses both so it is also
something that
will define how the shuttle value will
look like later on
um but you have to know these things if
you want to use sharepoint values
and inter interpret them correctly yeah
because
i think philosophically we've got we've
got the real behavior
and then we use these interpretability
methods and then we've got the kind of
perceived behavior so we've got these
these levels of modeling or or did you
know what i mean
simplification and it's all well and
true if you
are dealing with data scientists who
understand
how these you know methods work that's
fine
but invariably data scientists need to
present this information to lay people
and they are not going to understand
all of the various different trade-offs
and how information has been compressed
and and
lost and so on so do you see that as a
as a serious problem
uh yes but it's not a new problem it's
with any number that you read in any
newspaper
uh i mean so in a sense i mean when
you look at uh outcomes of statistical
models that uh
well everyone can understand well of
course not because you need training to
understand how to interpret a linear
model or any regression model
yeah there's this difficulty but i don't
think it's new in any sense
because there's always i mean any number
that you read anywhere has a very
complex process
um so i don't know if you have like
covert testing numbers it's very complex
like how the number was generated maybe
like how it was aggregated over many
states and like what cases it
includes in which it doesn't and so the
number looks very innocent and simple
but
there's a very long process behind it to
produce it
maybe this process is a bit uh
a bit more black box a bit more
difficult if it comes out if there's
some machine learning in between
machine learning model in between to
generate a number um
but yeah i think this problem is
well old well let me let me
challenge a little bit here on something
which is okay
if i have if i have some general formula
just some very general formula
and then i go in there and i go you know
what this formula has
five parameters and if i make this one
.75 and that one one third
and this one two and that one's zero and
i call this the
megatron you know uh activation
potential
and i go and write a paper about it
that's really just an
arbitrary you know kind of selection of
a bunch of numbers and then you gave it
a fancy
mathematical passport and you got it
published in some journal and now
everybody has to memorize
that as you know the megatron potential
and kind of learn about it and that's a
lot of what's going on right now
is that it's really just a bunch of
hacking like it's people just they don't
really know
a general solution and they don't know
how to solve like in general the problem
they're trying to solve
and so they just hack around and then
the ones that are kind of famous or
demonstrate some success in a particular
combination
you know competition over in this corner
or something it now becomes something
that's part of the lexicon that we all
have to learn
and i think like i look back on this
like imagine what physics was like
before
leibniz and newton you know invented
calculus it's like everybody memorizing
a whole bunch of little purpose-built
kind of formulas and then along comes a
general framework which now we can just
learn calculus
and derive the special circumstances as
needed you're onto something really
interesting there which is that
with iml methods we are we are kind of
compressing information down into a
representation
you know and then that that is a
transport that can be understood by
different people but
there's a trade-off right because as you
said you can learn calculus and that's a
compact framework for doing lots of
stuff but it's all about the amount of
common knowledge that is required
so it's possible to compress something
down
just to one symbol and that symbol could
represent all of that knowledge but it
doesn't help you because i still need to
learn all of that knowledge
yeah but so to me calculus was a very
beautiful
and simple framework that i could learn
and then once i learned that simple
thing
i could go and solve all kinds of
problems with it before i would have to
memorize specific solutions or like the
quadratic formula for example
as a student i didn't actually memorize
the quadratic formula i just learned how
to complete the square
and then then i would just do complete
the square and if somebody asked me what
the quadratic formula was i would just
quickly derive it right because it was
easier to memorize the rule and then
apply the rule to any situation
rather than to memorize all these little
one-off you know kinds of hacks
that we come up with you're not normal
keith right so most people
won't be able to go and understand this
because
these iml methods are brilliant for data
scientists who can
it it's a framework right so it's a
reference of understanding so assuming
that people can understand how shapley
values work
then this is a beautiful representation
to
to reason about the behavior of models
sure but when i when i first saw
shapley values i realized immediately
there's a connection
in you know bayesian analysis to
marginalization you know all we're
really doing here is computing
the expected marginal you know
contribution to this value it's not a
probability but it's still the same
procedure being done right and i think
i'm going to throw myself
in with the lay people to a degree
because the reason i'm always striving
for
simplifications is because i don't have
the capacity to memorize
all these little arbitrary kinds of
hacks and but i yet
i could totally understand bayesian
analysis and like i said
you know previously in some other videos
statistics made no sense to me until i
learned the bayesian framework
because that was based on very simple
rules that i could then
reapply as needed i think that
what you refer to keith um maybe the
worst situation is with the saliency
maps because you have so many methods
and they all like back propagate the
gradient
and to do input pixels
and to um now do you have to like
learn like how dozens of these framework
works or
like how um how to interpret do
interpretation of all of these
and they're all kind of variants of each
other so
mostly because they just there's some
ambiguity how
you uh how you back propagate the
gradient
um because um because of the non-linear
units and stuff
and uh little bit differences how you
can define this
and so you have this huge like sea
of um many different methods um
i i think it would be nice there for as
you said to have some
like simplification where you say okay
this is like
all these methods work under this one
principle basically and
we have these two parameters um and
that's how they define i think that's
also that uh
some i think i wrote something in a
chapter um
that please stop inventing new methods
for
saliency maps um so i i think it's
enough
and we should focus more on like doing
this consolidation
to like understand the limitations of
the methods and consolidate them to see
like what's the commonalities uh in
which ways do they differ and so on
that's probably actually my first
impression actually when i first opened
the interpretable ml book
that's amazing how many different things
there are i've you know heard people say
oh
you can't use machine learning it's just
a black box so many times
it almost been drilled into my head then
seeing all the things you know
from white box models ways of training
celebrate models counter factual
explanations
it's what a wonderful recipe right there
are so many different things that you
can do
i feel like now i trust ml models more
than other kinds of things because i
have
this amazing toolbox of ways to
understand them
the thing that strikes me though is most
of these methods as we were just saying
they require interpretation by a human
and a human who understands how the
method works
um i i love this concept of turning
machine learning into an engineering
discipline
and being able to do a lot of these
um tests non-interactively and i think
um
you know marco rubio has done a lot of
work around the counter factual examples
and the data grouping and
what what excites me about these methods
is they seem like methods that we could
actually run
as part of an automated process we still
have to set thresholds
maybe we could set a threshold that said
if this if this counter factual example
flips the switch on more than one
percent of examples then fail the build
that seems reasonable but a saliency
method i mean how the hell do you say
well
if there's lots of red pixels over here
then break the build i mean it's just
ridiculous isn't it
yeah yeah so i i also have seen
interesting approaches to um like using
interpretability also more
automatically like um when you do model
um monitoring you can do things like
uh create interpretations and see if
they significantly change over time for
example
um so then have thresholds that warn you
that
hey um something is going on with your
model
um so i think there's also interesting
approaches there
yeah you know tim to your point of
making this
an engineering field and even making
interpretability and
and understandability and engineering
field i mean i think that
maybe that's why i like your book so
much christoph is i think it's
it's a step towards that direction it's
like let's survey everything and more
importantly let's create
a finite and hopefully smallish set
of simple concepts that we can all agree
on and understand that we can use to
catalog you know what's out there so
please keep up the good work
you know i'm uh interested to see where
this goes so final question for you
christoph then i wonder what's
what's next for interpretability like
are we going to the point where it's
going to be
almost a box ticking exercise where we
can say yes our process we've done the
standard interpretability is that i mean
is it
is computing power going to change it i
remember when chap the library came out
to
made that approach possible whereas
previously you know it was very hard
very
computationally feasible my friend anjem
who's a wonderful data scientist
sent me nvidia records they've got that
running on gpus
way faster than of course before is it
just gonna become a standard
step do you think or is it gonna be
something where you need decent subject
matter expertise and some real thought
to do to really understand how a model
works um
so well predictions are what the future
are always hard so i'm
maybe more like what i wish or what it
yeah and we think we'll have could
happen
um so i mean what we're seeing already
is like a lot of
implementations of the these methods so
they're kind of getting
a commonality a rook one can use it uh
very easily
there's a lot of uh libraries out there
in python r
uh but also in like these machine
learning
um plow tools they also
have a lot of interpretation methods um
available now so
in that sense i think and it's maturing
a lot
um i i still believe that you need um
some expertise to understand them or at
least some good references
and there will also be hopefully more
than my book maybe have some uh
documentation when for for these tools
and people answering on stack overflow
questions and
whatnot um so i think um
yeah it's it's getting we're getting
that
everyone can use it easily i think
it should never be a box ticking
exercise it's a similar thing when
if you have an ai ethics you know
governance process or something
the last thing you want is for it just
to be an automatic response so i've just
you know yeah i've thought about ai
ethics
um it needs to be something that we
really engage with
i think we need to abstract away a lot
of the complexity at the moment
i think it's possible to come up with an
interface to standardize
the way that we do interpretability and
we can
reduce down what we have now to certain
primitives
which means that it can plug into an
engineering process and it also means
that
we can abstract away some of the
complexity and i think that's possible
yeah i i also would agree that it
shouldn't be like just box sticking but
you can like for the initial
um when you start interpreting a model
that you just have like
with a click you have a report and then
it shows you the most basic things
but then you still like should ask diff
like the question like does it really
make sense that this feature is the most
important one
or what's happening there with these
weird interactions between the two
features
let's uh dig a bit deeper here and see
what's going on so i think
um there's this one portion that is just
like this
automated reporting thing um but this
should then be like the starting point
for more critical
uh questioning of the model or and
and checking what's going on um for some
specific
problems maybe so it's going to be you
click on the molnar report
and it gives you the the report from the
book right
yeah that would be convenient well um
christophe monarch thank you very much
for joining us today it's an absolute
honor to have you on the show thanks for
having me
hey folks this is tim in postscript
there's just a couple of thoughts that
didn't come to my mind during the
interview that i think i'd like to
quickly cover now the first thing is on
the lack of fairness the reason why
i raised that is most folks who talk
about ai ethics and fairness they
use the toolkit of interpretability
methods quite often
you know to apply their trade there are
tools out there
to mitigate fairness and to detect
fairness microsoft's fair learner is a
great example of this
what we really need is an operating
model or a set of
guidelines on how to implement these
tools
how do i identify sources of problematic
correlations
we need to have a database of
problematic correlations
having a tool that allows me to identify
mitigate bias frankly
is useless what do i do with that as we
mentioned on the show
many of the machine learning cloud
providers whether it's data iq or
azure ml and sagemaker they all have
these interpretability methods built in
now
including saliency maps and it's just a
box ticking exercise frankly
it's completely useless there is no
accepted
guidance on how these tools should be
used right so
if i'm a large company and i'm building
an operating model around how to
implement fairness techniques
just having the technology is irrelevant
it's about the people and the process
and the the kind of operating model of
how we implement it and
there is basically no useful information
out there to help us do that
the other thing is we spoke about this
becoming an engineering discipline
which is to say what if we could create
an interface to abstract away some of
the vagaries and esoteric of
interpretability methods we might
come up with some primitives or some
common language
and then we can hide the complexity
behind the interface this is kind of
what we do with mo devops already
we automate as much as we can then we
templatize and remove friction out of
the process
we even create building blocks using
domain specific languages or
yaml files and pipelines and and so on
so
what we do is we we create a level of
abstraction where people can compose
together
pipelines remember when connor made the
comment that this might just become a
box ticking exercise and this is
something we see in security and ai
ethics already we can't really trust
people to self-report
that the model is behaving correctly or
that the project has no
concerns from an ai ethics point of view
the whole point here is process
if we want to create an operating model
and ensure best
practices are followed or any kind of
standardization
in a large organization we have to
design a process
and many eyes make shallow holes so
the process would mandate that a certain
number of stakeholders were involved in
assessing the particular iml
technique and validating it essentially
and then we would need to record that
assessment so who said what when
and then if the company ever became
audited or if
god forbid there was some kind of a
problem where the iml model did
something wrong and it caused the
company lots of damage or
it harmed the environment or society or
something like that we would then be
able to rewind the clock and say okay
well
joe blogs said it was okay because of
xyz
so that is an operating model it's a
process
and how to design such a process again
is
completely absent speaking as a chief
data scientist myself
that's the kind of thing that i'm
interested in and
it's very difficult for me to do that i
really hope you've enjoyed the episode
today we've had so much fun making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
and we'll see you back
next week